time to hit the drive-through shamrock
shakes our back and so is st. Patrick's
aid but how Irish is this holiday this
global celebration known for drinking
anything green has Emerald Isle roots
but it's come a long way from its origin
st. Patrick's Day started out as a
solemn holiday to commemorate the patron
saint who brought Christianity to
Ireland and until the 1700s this annual
feast was only celebrated there but when
Irish immigrants came to the United
States they celebrated the state to
reconnect with their homeland and to
push back against anti Irish
discrimination religious services
expanded into other displays of Irish
pride parades kicked off in cities like
New York Boston and Chicago and soon
spread to the rest of the country since
then st. Patrick's Day has become a
worldwide celebration of leprechauns and
rivers dyed green it's a day when
everyone is Irish or at least pretends
to be